I don't know how  I got to write those songs what do you  mean you don't know how  they were oh those early songs were like  almost magically written  um uh Darkness at the breaking noon  Shadows even the Silver Spoon handmade  blade a child's balloon eclipses both  the sun and moon to understand you know  too soon there is no sense in trying  well  try to sit down and write something like  that  there's a magic to that and it's not uh  Siegfried and Roy kind of magic you know  it's a it's a different kind of a  penetrating Magic  and uh you know I did it I I did it at  one time  you don't think you can do it today  does that disappoint you well you can't  do something forever and uh I did it  once and I can do other things now but  I can't do that